alright Chamberlain Heights I hope
you're ready for tonight's game over at
Duncan against Hoover good junior high
one win and Duncan will be in the
playoffs for the first time ever and out
of the game hang around for the jersey
retirement for the all-time leading
scorer and Duncan high history Montrell
Cummings his brother plays on the team
as well but he don't get no bird Tim the
whole town know you were bench writer
now no
I'll never be a legend if I don't get
off the bench don't sweat that pimp I
feel like we're gonna get our shot soon
and when we do we gonna blow up bigger
than Jamal's mom after eating peanuts ha
ha ha that's funny
speaking of mom with big titties hey
miss milk marry kill me Grover milk
that's a good question I definitely
your mom mom how the hell you
gonna him all over your own son I
knew you was a cop cause I gotta go by
myself at you my mom get your life
together
yeah that's me baby
they retiring my jersey so you want to
go for a ride in my boys party hurts
it's got its own Starbucks coffee bean a
cocoa butter machine and an Asian woman
in the back do your nails
all thanks to my home shea butter yeah
yeah that's right
my heart is the it even got a dial
plated but I I can't even your hair some
chips
oh and one two shots at the line black
holes
oh oh oh my god oh oh and then here it's
with the oh oh God and adherence with
the rule oh I will somebody get this
kid man
Oh God and here's what the rules the
opposing coach will select another
Duncan player to replace the injured one
[Music]
how do it you ain't gonna do you
ain't got off the bench all year you
broke jumper we'll take
them
[Music]